now coming up in the course of the night
live coverage on the ground all
throughout Israel with Trey Gallagher
Steve harrian Alex Hogan and Lieutenant
Colonel Oliver North also former
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo he will
be with us his analysis probably needed
more than ever both their analysis first
here's what we know so far from Israel's
ground Invasion which some are now
saying could last for months a very key
objective we now know has to be for the
IDF to destroy the vast network of
tunnels constructed by Hamas under Gaza
City I've been in them now the concrete
tunnels by the way which have power
ventilation were constructed under
International Aid they used
international Aid money a lot of that
money happened to be your tax dollars
money that was intended for the
Palestinian people keep that in mind
when Joe Biden tries to pit you on the
$100 million in humanitarian aid for the
Palestinians but this money instead of
building this network of tunnels should
have been used for infrastructure
schools and hospitals but instead used
by the terror group Hamas for shelter
travel the coordination of attacks to
capture kill kidnap Israelis and they
also used for the storage of their
weaponry and many other day-to-day
operations now sadly this underground
network was built below residential
areas why of course in order to use
civilians above as human Shields now
take a look at your screen this
animation shows how Hamas actually built
their terrorist headquarters directly
under underneath gaza's largest hospital
I wonder if that's the same hospital
that was blown to Smither by the
Israelis when it never got hit and it
was from the Islamic Jihad this was when
the media lied to you and it just flat
out destroyed that that butchered that
story most of these medials never took
responsibility and by the way that hurt
Israel because they had to reveal their
intelligence gathering capability just
to prove they did not do this they
didn't do it this is one of the reasons
the IDF has been pleading with residents
now for almost 21 straight days in Gaza
now to move South of the city now
unfortunately the freedom loving
terrorists of Hamas you know uh the
people that have been praised all around
University campuses in our country they
are preventing civilians from actually
evacuating according to a phone call
between an IDF Soldier and a resident of
Gaza Hamas is blocking roads even
shooting at people as they flee listen
for
yourself
speee
for
are you are
you now the people of Gaza they're never
going to be free living under the thumb
of the ter terrorist group Hamas this is
a truly barbaric group of indoctrinated
terrorists Thugs who will always be
terrorists masquerading as the world's
ultimate victims convert or die remember
death to Israel death to America
remember we should maybe start listening
what of the 9911 commission report tell
us uh they were at war with us we were
not at war with them they've been firing
tens of thousands of missiles annually
into Israel they built this network of
tunnels to kill Israelis they're at War
war with Israel they have declared war
leading up to this October 7th event
Hamas is about to lose their brutal grip
on the people of Gaza whatever is left
of Gaza Israel has vowed to take him out
rightly so and now faced with the
reality for the first time in years the
leaders of Hamas are not taking it well
watch this recent BBC interview with the
spokesperson for Hamas take a look you
say this was a military operation but
the result of it was that hundreds of C
were killed because the area is very
wide and there are many people there and
there was clashes and confrontation it's
not confrontation you invaded houses
details what happened inside but I I
can't tell you that we didn't have any
intention or decision to call the
civilians how do you justify killing
people as they sleep you know Families
how do you Jus I want to stop this
interview I want to stop this interview
yeah how do you justify beheading babies
uh good question sorry uh I don't want
this interview you know it's harder to
lie when you don't have a captive
audience ultimately know this Israel
will eliminate Hamas from this Earth
they will prevail as their very
existence now depends on it they're also
prepared to eliminate Hezbollah in the
North in a two-front war if necessary
probably even likely at this point
Iran's proxy wars they have been very
very active for years and very active
this month but they're not just
attacking Israel the United States let
no know this and understand it is also
in their their their sites Iran's
proxies have launched a series of
attacks against American soldiers
stationed in the Middle East so far at
least 24 soldiers have been injured
including some with traumatic brain
injuries last night after weeks of doing
nothing Biden finally authorized what
turned out to be a very small air strike
against two warehouses owned by Iranian
proxies or as Senator Tom Cotton put it
quote retaliation against Expendable uh
expend Expendable proxies especially
unoccupied proxy warehouses merely
validates Iran's strategy to use proxies
to attack Americans they are laughing at
us in Tyran and in Tyran and Iran and
we'll Target and we'll continue to
Target Americans until President Biden
gets serious about imposing severe costs
on Iran so far Iran has suffered no real
consequences for any of their action is
quite the opposite they keep getting
rewarded by Joe Biden the oil keeps
going out billions of dollars keeps
coming in the mull sleep safe and sound
uh not a care in the world weakness of
Joe Biden has invited hostility and
aggression worldwide and no one has been
weaker than this President he has more
Fury against so-called ultr Maga
Republicans than the terrorists now
attacking our soldiers and we're going
to have a lot more on Iran's hostility
coming up tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else